you ever like listen to those like like
news shows or like a podcast where
someone comes on they're like
you know
oh man just like oh god why yeah there
was one particular person i don't
remember who it was on npr that was like
i would i would almost crash my car into
a tree on the drive into the office
because on purpose
oh yeah just to end it all because i
couldn't handle that between every word
yeah there's one guy on there that i
feel like
[Laughter]
well i can't
on this we're going to beep out the cuss
words or no no anything else there's
anybody who's listening to this i think
well i'm excited for the children to
listen
i think the children are going to listen
either way all right listen up you
little [ __ ]
[Music]
very nostalgic to watch that particular
episode because as listener at home
might not know
that actually was our pilot certain
scenes from that are from the pilot and
that that was based on the home movie
version of the show that we cooked up
yeah it was actually a combination of
the first two home movies that we used
to sell the show that first scene where
i come over to your apartment and you
know i ask you if you have a basketball
that was actually the impetus behind the
entire show that was the scene that
started it all that was before we'd ever
conceived of it as a show or a short
film or anything i remember rob coming
over to my apartment being like hey i
woke up in the middle of the night
thinking about this scene and just
laughing my ass off and you coming over
and be like i
i started thinking about this and i i
wanted to do something where we took a
subject that is traditionally impossible
to make comedic and figure out a way to
make it funny and that was the challenge
and you wrote did you write it in the
middle of the night yeah i wrote it that
that you woke up and wrote it yeah yeah
you were like half asleep half dreaming
about no i was just up late probably
from all the coffee and cigarettes let
me ask you something about this will be
an interesting question because we just
watched this five minutes ago and i
can't remember whether or not we saw
something that was in it but
in the one that we watched which we
switched it to a basketball which i
think isn't as good as coming over for
sugar
but
that the guys were waiting for you in
the car
we shot a thing where you then hop in
the car was that yes was that and it was
it was cut out right yeah we cut it we
shot that in pasadena because we needed
bricks
we couldn't find bricks anywhere i don't
know why but we did go to philly so i
don't know why we didn't shoot in philly
i think because we added that scene or
something like that so we had to shoot
in l.a but yeah but the oh so the
original scene that one scene it was a
little bit different from what we wound
up
using in the home movie we did a bunch
of improv on the day but then when we
wound up cutting it and having it work
we then took that scene almost verbatim
and put it into the pilot that we shot
for fx in fact your performances are
very specific we were recreating what
we'd already we were and by the way that
i don't know if you remember this but we
also shot that scene that scene we shot
probably 10 times yeah over the course
of like two years we were just
experimenting we were trying to we were
just working it out you know i mean it
was like almost like working on a sword
just trying to find
ways to make terrible terrible terrible
characters into funny relatable people
and so that just take it just took time
a lot of awkward pauses in that scene i
was very fascinated with the idea of
like very very awkward kind of comedy
you know just based on
what were probably my biggest influences
at the time which was the british office
and curb your enthusiasm just so much
like
awkward uncomfortable comedy kind of
stuff that we i still like that yeah
yeah i like i like it too but yeah we do
less and less of it we'll do lessons but
i like it yeah yeah but we shot that
scene multiple multiple times by the
time we shot that pilot version for fx
that was probably the tenth time we shot
it yeah i mean it's great but that
episode we jammed a lot of stuff in that
episode uh story yeah a lot of story
some of it you know a little bit
problematic but we've addressed that
over the years and you know we are
making a show about terrible people yeah
however we know we have certain blind
spots that we have admitted to over the
years and we try to ameliorate that as
we go but i think overall from a
structural standpoint it seems to hold
together pretty well this is a little
off topic rob i noticed you're talking
so close to the microphone
that your lips are like touching the
little pop guard
yeah you were like you were you were
talking like that your lips were like on
the on the thing it wants to suck it but
it's too you know what it is i think i
think that my
megan is
i can't hear myself very well and so i i
thought maybe that's just the way the
mics are designed
you're not seeing me right now but i'm
like really i mean you were right you
were nestled you should not have to
crane your neck that far forward you
should not have to see a chiropractor
after doing a podcast there's also got
something kind of it feels very rare i
wasn't judging you but feeling insecure
about myself like oh my god maybe i'm
not close i'm not close enough to the
mic yeah because i can hear you
perfectly i sound like i'm in a
different room no yeah not in my cans oh
okay great uh listener when when i say
cans i'm talking about headphones
um that episode was directed by mr rob
mcelhenny himself who originally when we
shot the original version of the home
movie was not in the show at all just
wanted to write and direct correct did
not want to act in it so mr david
hornsby who eventually of course went on
to play rickety cricket played the
original character whose name was rob
and rob just wanted to direct and let's
get into that for a second yeah now why
were you thinking you were done with the
acting thing because you then you know
did obviously you've done mac on the
show
you're killing it in mythic quests uh
you've gone on to do some other work
here in the paradise
not a lot i know it's not a priority for
you but
but you are lost i think you said a lot
of lost
i think they cut you out of game of
thrones the point is though i know you
like i know you like being in front of
the camera so why was it at that age
let's let's go back to young rob and be
like what was it that made you think you
know i'm just going to be behind the
camera well i don't know that i was
making that like clear of a distinction
i was just afraid that if there wasn't
somebody behind it's not like we had
like playback or anything so i was like
holding the camera and looking at it i
was just afraid that we wouldn't have
enough people it was a qc issue for you
it was a quality control yeah like but
also probably and i don't want to put
words in your mouth to correct me if i'm
wrong but i mean we were friends with
hornsby at the time and hornsby was just
one of the funniest [ __ ] people we'd
ever met so i think you probably were
like well somebody's got to be behind
the cameras watching this thing as it
goes down to make sure it's working and
then hornsby can just play i also like
i'm i'm really not saying this to
out of any kind of like false humility
i'm really not i never considered myself
like a super funny performer i always
thought i could write funny stuff i
remember when i gave you that script and
i was like i don't think i could pull
this off but i feel like maybe the two
of you could make this seem really funny
and then sure enough you did so then my
thought was like well why not just
populate with really funny people that
can make this dark material really funny
and i can see myself even in this
episode you know for the first
year or two really trying to find my way
and in fact
it'll come up more and more often but i
saw things that charlie was doing in
that episode that i know that i like
directly ripped off like later in the
season and then like no
yeah
yeah
it's like it's like you know we've all
stolen each other's moves yeah we share
the wealth it's it's osmosis was what
happens it's not intentional it's not
like i'm going to do that thing no no
it's just like oh i saw somebody do that
and it was funny and in the moment i'm
trying to be funny and i just yeah it
just comes out you're you're registering
it subconsciously as funny and then you
sort of end up doing it but emulating it
and i didn't think i have an enough
experience at the time being funny so i
was just like around these really funny
people and was like well you were always
a funny guy
but you did not think you were a funny
performer because as an actor you'd done
you know mostly drama at that point
that's right i mean yeah but not even
not even a lot of that mostly i had done
a lot of uh waiting tables yeah did it
occur to you that maybe drama wasn't the
way to go when you got cut out of every
single [ __ ] film you shot yeah i mean
there's there's evidence out there to
really suggest that i should have given
up a long time ago yeah with those
movies that you got cut out but before
you get into that though there was zero
evidence to support you being a writer
director yeah even less it says it's
interesting that you were like yeah this
is gonna
without a doubt without a doubt yeah
yeah no there was no evidence to suggest
that i should have succeeded at either
of those disciplines and a lot of
unsubstantiated confidence in your own
ability to pull something off yes yeah
yeah that's that again i think that goes
back we were talking about show business
in general you just summed it up the
only way that anyone ever does anything
is to say hey i think i can do this with
absolutely unless you wake up looking
like a supermodel yeah and then you're
like yeah maybe people will want to
watch my face and yeah if i can learn
how to talk good i know people want to
look at my face yeah the rest of it will
work itself we start talking good we
start talking good after today and maybe
movies come me way yes i just heard tina
fey was just i just heard her say this
exact thing she said acting pretty much
is
99
having a face that people want to look
at it helps to have a great face she was
saying is really attractive or just
really interesting to look at doesn't
necessarily have to be like really
attractive but it's just a face that
people are want to look at
it it does do a lot of the work for you
when you have a really compelling face
you know what i mean when your face is
constantly
scrunched up like clint eastwood's you
know i mean you get well he is also he's
also really handsome but then you also
can win the war of attrition if you're
the only person that can like really put
in because you're willing to put in 12
hours a day and write everything and
constantly keep creating it and then
saying well if you want this then i have
to be in it then you kind of force your
way in that's it yeah and that's why a
lot of people do that that's what i mean
yeah more and more these days so i don't
know that people want to look at my face
but they're being forced to i like your
face i think your face looks great on
camera oh thanks i i do yeah i think
it's more interesting than mine
certainly i think i think i sort of have
a neutral face like kind of good looking
but not that good-looking and i i feel
like i have to go pretty big with my
acting
in order to remain interesting i have to
make big choices as an actor i can't
like i tried early on in my career to
just kind of do that thing of like okay
i'm just gonna feel the feelings of the
character and just know that it'll shine
through my eyes and what i saw was just
just [ __ ] flat dead performances
across the board i was just like oh my
god every [ __ ] time
where you're like i really was feeling
that yeah like and really dropped into
it then you watch it and you're like
well there's nothing there dead eyes
dead eyes just dead eyes he's got dead
eyes yeah uh that's that's my dr larry
meyer's impression of talking of ethan
he came i love ethan hawke he came up to
me and wait sorry so who dr larry myers
larry myers you remember he had the
beanie baby yes i got a job directing
downtown theater mostly guys
told these stories
for the last 15 years and it's a serious
before you not remembering it's not it's
not all for you rob we're not performing
for you you're not directing our lives
oh tell the story of doctor larry that
you've talked to that you've heard
uh yeah i told him i bumped into him he
had he had a play called beanie baby
addiction
remember this and then uh you know it
was the kind of thing was like 90
monologues i was like maybe we could cut
it down to like
eight
and uh he's like fine and then fine
don't do too much director stuff that's
fine i just need the money and uh you
know like then there'd be like a kid
who'd come over from new jersey was like
18 and he'd do his monologue and i'd be
like all right let's talk about like who
do you think you're talking to in the
scene or whatever and larry would cut it
and be like i think he should be wearing
bicycle shorts and lifting weights and
then his dad would get him back in the
truck and drive in new jersey and we'd
never see the kid again anyway
larry stopped me on the street and said
hi and uh this was years ago and i told
him i was gonna play with ethan hawk and
he goes ethan hawk has dead eyes
got dead eyes i'm like i don't well i
disagree larry we disagree we
talk one of the best one of the best
absolutely [ __ ] incredible and an
amazing artist love true artist dr larry
meyers and that makes me think of the uh
that's the director rob
sweetie's acting teacher uh
was that that character's name was dr
meyers wasn't it yes that was based on
doctor
larry myers you know what i do think
though your voice is a part of it too
right like keanu reeves always got a rap
for like not being a great actor
obviously the man is a very good actor
he can carry like a major motion picture
and you will love that movie and be
highly entertained
but because he has this affectation when
he talks
you know
that's gonna not sound great if you're
doing like uh
shakespeare hamlet yeah you're playing
hamlet so it's just that voice but the
actual belief of the words that he's
saying and the
conveying of it is fine it's just if
you're stuck doing that because i
venture to say that people watch keanu
reeves movies for his face more than his
voice no he's
that's i'm saying the same thing i'm
saying his voice does a big part i think
it's a it's his his face is a big part
of it you just like him yeah you just
like him and you want him to succeed and
that in and of itself is like talent
or just genetics i don't know you know
he's compelling to watch there's no
doubt about it i this still makes me
laugh to this day thinking of keanu
reeves and point break a movie that i
absolutely love
where when they find out that the that
the fbi wants to put him under cover
as a surfer
keanu reeves has i believe this is the
exact line it could be wrong or maybe
i'm paraphrasing but his line is and
said like this
the fbi
wants to pay me to learn how to surf
like as if the it's like the subtext
behind that is like
why would they pick me for that no one's
gonna buy that bro
pick somebody else man who's gonna
believe i'm a surfer like what do they
even like sound like yeah exactly
i'm from idaho man
i'm a football player dude i don't know
[ __ ] about surfing bro
he's not johnny utah from utah i think
so oh get the [ __ ] out of here from you
know it's like a
that was like his nickname yeah yeah
yeah i think that was his [ __ ] name
i think that was the character's actual
name yeah maybe johnny utah or did he
play at the university of utah well hold
on a second because they they referenced
that i can't remember
what roach said they remember playing
football on the
on the beach yeah he blows his knee out
he blows his knee out and then they and
then and then swayze says bodhi says uh
don't you guys know who this is this is
johnny utah yeah and then they remember
playing him playing maybe it was that's
right or something they're like oh [ __ ]
yeah and then he's in and you know and
that's why not because he's anything
like a surfer dude like the fbi wants to
pay me
to learn how to surf
dude
i'm [ __ ] i'm gonna find out like right
away dude bummer dude bomberman totally
not
[Laughter]
[Music]
bodacious do you guys have any other
stories about making the fx pilot that
you think would be interesting to the
listener because uh well we shot a good
chunk of that in philadelphia we did and
then and then a good chunk of it in los
angeles and oddly enough if anybody is
uh interested enough to go back and
experience this as we are which is to
watch the episodes again you'll notice
that charlie's apartment looks like the
set of
a grade school production it looks like
the night man comes yes not the
interesting fact that was not a set that
was a real apartment that we painted
apparently to look like is that actually
i wonder if we even painted it or if
there's no way we just dropped oh oh you
mean because maybe somebody else had
painted it for some other show or
something yeah someone because we were i
don't think i think we painted i don't
think we were painting things yet or
anything like that i think it was like
go in dress the place think about that
pilot think about the budget of that
pilot right
we weren't people we didn't have a ton
of money and in fact there's a scene
that happens maybe no one else can
notice it but there's a scene that
happens where i'm in the street with
carmen having i think it's a part of the
montage and you can very clearly see
that i still have like the remnants of a
black eye
which has not happened in the story yet
but we had shot the scene already we had
a strong makeup department but i don't
think we had good video playback so i
don't think you could see it yeah on
camera yeah the whole thing was pretty
we're finding our way finding our way
pretty low rent rob two of your buddies
from philly are in that episode yes
dennis hart and dennis hogan yeah and
they play
they play the construction worker number
one and construction worker number two
that's right hogan and heart the classic
comedy duo i love it that is by the way
great
yeah they've come back musicals and they
i know they came back in the world
series defense episode but have they
been in other ones too
i think it was just that maybe not maybe
i think it was a call back in the same
scene where they're like they see me
fighting the map is that guys beating on
the on
[Laughter]
i just spoke with dennis hogan this
morning rob why don't you tell people
what my character's name is based on i
have a number of friends named dennis
yep and then one of my best friend's
name is tom reynolds right and so i just
refused those together for dennis and
reynolds but who knows i mean we were
knocking around all sorts of different
ideas no that is what it was that's what
it was no absolutely you had you had two
close friends dennis hart and dennis
hogan yeah who were in the episode so
you went with dennis and then you didn't
want it to be their last name so you did
yeah so it was a shout out to old tommy
reynolds and then we went with mac and
then charlie charlie was just charlie
because well mac was your no i mean i
used to call you back
that was your name that was your actual
nickname well because when we did the
original like home version of it we
weren't changing our character's names
yeah right and my friends have had to
stop calling me mac because that's what
they used to call me because now it's
weird to call me that
i will say the one really great thing
about me not changing my name is when
someone yells at me in the streets it's
not it's i don't have that like hey
kramer moment i assume
they are just such big fans of me as the
person that it can fill my my cup
without uh knocking me down a peg yeah
we can talk about the name sweet d
oh yeah which is a which is a tad
problematic it's got an interesting
etymology when i first moved to los
angeles i moved with chris backus buddy
of mine from new york and we very early
on we were only out here for a few weeks
chris is a very handsome person i think
we may have talked about chris already
on the first podcast yeah
we were at this barbecue and he met mira
sorvita i was
yeah i was there too no no that wasn't a
barbecue we went to a couple of tom
morello's barbecues but
no this was a night where we played um
we played that game but that was not
running charades that was that was a
game night in west hollywood at samantha
yes was it her house yes oh yeah and so
i mean this was now 17 years ago or
something like that this would have been
back in 2004. yeah it was a group of
friends and tom morello was one of the
people there tom morello who's the uh
lead guitarist of rage against machine
audio slave one of the greatest
musicians alive
um his girlfriend at the time now wife
everybody kept referring to her as sweet
d and i always thought that's that's an
interesting funny name
sweet d
why do they call her that i don't know
and then i kind of forgot about it right
for like
like three years three years i forgot
about it and then when i sat down to
write the show i i don't know why it
popped in my head i was like maybe they
call her sweet d that's kind of fun
yeah that's just a touch your lips
he wants to suck it i'm telling you he
wants to suck it so bad but it's not the
right [ __ ] it's not the right thing you
don't feel that scrape it against the
front of your face man anyway continue
with this riveting story yeah he likes
it it's soft
yeah you're in it though
it's like sucking them up at stick yeah
you're still kind of you're friendly
with tom i'm friendly with tom uh i
haven't seen yeah has no they're married
yes and so we've run into each other
over the years but again like we didn't
know that this stupid show was gonna go
forever i also
like i didn't put it together that i was
stealing this person's name which of
course i was i didn't even i didn't put
it together either even though i knew
who she was too then i got word
from bacchus like hey denise is not
psyched and i was like [ __ ] of course
she's not psyched because i've
and it turns out that it was a nickname
that tom
gave her oh so it was like a very
meaningful name yes and i i've felt
guilt-ridden and you ruined it you
ruined that special thing that they had
i know
does that make you feel powerful that
you were able to ruin something and
someone is safe
i'm gonna come in here in your defense
for a second you don't own ever even if
it's your personal pet now if it was
like you were every time you said the
name you put a picture of her face up
there like but that it's it's you don't
own that's not they're there it is very
it's just very specific what was
happening like in the beginning nobody
watched the show so nobody gave the [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden becomes popular
and then people are like oh i noticed
that people call you sweet is that name
yeah
and then she's gotta be like no they
stole my well look yeah i have that
issue with my good college buddy brendan
mcpoyle which is
uh you know which we were doing as like
a cool shout out like it wouldn't be fun
to hear your name on the show and then
like
no it's yeah because it's associated
with not
mentally strong yeah the characters take
on their own life and uh yeah yeah and
then all right i'm sorry
i don't even know you brendan so i don't
know yeah i don't give a [ __ ] is that an
earthquake oh we're having another
earthquake
oh
whoa i don't think so
yeah that wasn't her that was that was
an earthquake it certainly sounded like
one was that you did you fart i didn't
feel anything rumble though you didn't
i
i heard the rumble but i didn't feel it
yeah i heard it rumble but i didn't feel
it listen man this is one of the newer
buildings it's probably very earthquake
safe and you know that's pretty cool i'm
gonna say we had an earthquake i think
it's more fun for listener at home if
we've just been through an earthquake
yeah that's exciting it certainly seemed
like an earthquake to me megan's looking
it up i have been hit up multiple times
as i think you guys have on social media
about like who's the thrice no nobody's
talking about that
everyone wants to know who the thrice
fan is
i don't know what thrice is and here's
the thing i don't know about you guys i
have never [ __ ] heard of that band i
have never heard any of their music i
apologize if they're a great band and
they've got fans out there i'm not
saying they're bad i've never heard them
before so that was a choice made by the
set decorator the art department on the
show to stick some thrice stickers up
there and we didn't know it was a band
we didn't know and now all of a sudden
there's all these thrice stickers and
god knows has it done anything for their
careers has has it helped you guys out
thrice i like to think so you know maybe
i don't know unless your music [ __ ] in
which case you just simply don't deserve
it
well it can't be not bad if they have
fans who are reaching out excited about
the stickers so you know they're
reaching somebody all right they are
reaching something good for you thrice
yeah right stickers everywhere
everywhere i don't know what that band
is i know i apologize thrice i don't
wonder how they named that band they
were like twice no that's not good
enough yeah what about what's more than
twice
grace all right that's one more yeah one
more all right what about
all right oh another interesting thing
about this episode which we picked up on
is a lot of our music cues that we used
for the rest of the run of the show we
found then yeah which was from a library
of music by the way which is rented out
everywhere like you'll hear the sunny
transition
songs and it's a very popular library of
music it's used in a lot of commercials
it's being used in this podcast right
now it is yes has that been decided well
meg's been cutting i don't know it's
just it's above above our budget i think
we might want to consider using a thrice
song okay so let's talk we have an
earthquake meg
no we did it somebody rolled the car oh
my god
that's how shell shocked we are in
california like we are ready at any
moment for that [ __ ] to go down yeah
first earthquake i ever felt
was in our editing suite on seward and
we were cutting season one or season two
of sunny you remember that you didn't
feel any earthquakes prior no it was a
big one i remember it was a big one i
don't remember that i mean we had a big
one season four when we were shooting in
culver city this is how i remember it
because you know i don't know if you
guys have this but my my family is
always like oh california why would you
want to live there all the earthquakes
and stuff and you're like you know it's
not constantly
earthquakes you might have a little
rumble here and there but it's pretty
fine they're like i don't know i would
never do it you know and then my sister
was visiting and of course like one week
she's visiting because we have a pretty
like the biggest earthquake i've had
[ __ ] really just reinforcing their
hysteria
ah that's funny do you guys remember the
first time we saw
the editor's cut oh the abortion one
where it was full of record scratches oh
[ __ ] and like i don't remember that
and we had hired like a composer
right we tried to work with a composer
and then we realized this is taking way
too long and as like young
people making something what you start
to realize is anytime you make anything
the first time you see it you're like oh
this is a disaster we've ruined
everything
only because [ __ ] up the journey from
what's in your mind to what's actually
what you shoot what it feels like on the
day to what's actually there there's a
process of
a different lens each time right it's
it's one thing in your head it's another
thing on the page it's another thing on
the day you find it in the edit i mean
and now luckily we've been doing this
for so long and we've worked with the
same editors for so long that now we
walk into an editor's cut and we're like
well it's a lot closer we're pretty much
done here yeah well we know how to
get to where we want to be much quicker
now but
the first time we
saw the cut of some of the stuff that
we'd shot
and it was an editor who we hadn't
worked with he was a great editor but
like um
you know he was doing very sort of
commercial tv
approach to it yeah
it was devastating fair enough yeah but
we watched it we were like this this
this is real we're done yeah we're gone
you'd say a line and be like
threw in some ah
[Laughter]
yeah we always want to talk about the
fact that we did a we did the rick
astley song before yeah rick rolling was
a thing we invent that no we i'm sure i
don't know what's going on
people were watching the show for us to
have invented it you never know man you
plant a seed and uh you know his songs
are like they're fun to sing in his like
very specific style of singing and my
sister and i used to sing all of his
songs whenever they would come on the
radio we'd be sitting in the back seat
and we'd be singing and yeah i think the
kind of [ __ ] my sister and i used to do
when we were kids and it's exactly the
kind of things that my kids do that
drive me [ __ ] nuts
and now i get it i you know i've told my
parents i'm like i get it guys i'm so
sorry like my mom used to make us sit at
a different table like at dinner she'd
be like i can't we had a kids table in
our house because she couldn't stand us
she hated us we were insufferable and
she was right were you fighting all the
time is that was that what it was you
were constantly battling no we were just
we wouldn't we just we were loud and we
were full of joy we were full of joy
yeah we were making sounds terrible we
were making each other well it was it
was just you know it's like i don't know
like my kids kind of do that and i'm
just like can you just [ __ ] eat
can you just [ __ ] eat
yeah i need you to go to bed so i can
have at least an hour to myself
get out of here
finish your dinner get in the bath
go to sleep and leave
me
alone
and you've said that now they just laugh
at you when you say that like yeah
because they pick up funny yeah there
because i am
and and i have to explain that i'm not
trying to be funny and they're like
daddy you don't know how to be angry and
not funny
daddy
son i'm not joking get out of here
set up hollywood
shut up shut the [ __ ] up hollywood
[Music]
what is the purpose of this for you rob
why are you doing this podcast what
excites you about it same reason we do
the show
it's fun i i don't know why we still do
the show so i have fun too oh you're
having fun i spend
at least forty to fifty percent of the
day laughing out loud yeah well where
else are you gonna be i have a lot of
fun on set
once we get to set you so you have not
been having fun by the way listen right
the writing's hard we are in the middle
of things right in season 15 right now
or what week four or five into the
writing process and we are avoiding it
by doing this podcast yeah the writing
the writing is the writing is the
hardest part it's the hardest part yeah
that's brutal there are definitely
moments of fun um and charlie's right
when we're on set when we're acting
together that's probably the most fun
but this is fun too i like doing this
podcast with you guys i wouldn't say
today's the best episode but uh you know
you're gonna have your today's the one
where we spoke the most clearly like we
stop down for a second have an actual
conversation from time to time which
maybe is interesting to people i don't
know no either i don't feel like we were
that funny today no you know what i mean
like i feel this pressure to be funny
because we're you know the shots
i was laughing were you laughing meg meg
was laughing but you don't again she
doesn't have a microphone so you can't
tell
we should have like um like a phone
number like old school phone number like
a hotline yeah where people can call and
they can basically tell us how much they
love or hate an episode yeah and then
maybe we can i would love a live call
that sounds very funny one live call i'm
the kind of person that when the office
phone rings and i answer it and it's
like spam i engaged in 45 minutes as
long as possible where i'm like okay
yeah i'd love to give you my um credit
card information can i know a little bit
more about your company
and then i say hey it's not a problem
that i work for the fbi right like
that's not an issue for you guys and
then
they usually hang up right around that
oh we have fun we have fun charlie likes
to have fun in any situation
you know most situations he'll take a
situation that would irritate the
average person and go how can i make
this fun
yeah
yeah two wars two wars
well think about that that was an
episode that seems like it was a hundred
years ago and we were talking about
wasn't we were talking about podcasts
you guys were doing a podcast we were we
were doing podcasts right yeah it was
basically you guys won that radio
contest max big break and we thought
like these [ __ ] knuckleheads they
don't do anything they just talk and
listen to themselves and they do like
stupid sound effects and we were like we
have more interesting conversations than
those guys and so we're like let's do a
podcast
that's kind of what this is uh my face
is all over this yeah i can't yeah well
it's like it's not so bad that you do it
and what's funny is that it startles you
yeah i get i get yeah
it's probably a while i get too close
and it bothers the pop car well also
like you're probably the
your breath is like hitting the pop
guard then splashing you back in the
face you're like a [ __ ] like a cat
getting sprayed by a spray bottle you
know because you got up on the counter
there's just some spatial awareness
issues happening with you which is like
you did no no
i thought you said your eyes were doing
okay right yeah my eyes are all right
doesn't seem like it it's my nose it's
your nose and lips that just don't know
where to go yeah so your eyes are okay
but you don't know where your nose is
i think we're getting somewhere yeah
yeah okay what do you think that is i
don't know you don't know where your
nose is anymore actually jokes aside
what do you think it is like why why is
your face actually continuing why do you
feel compelled to touch the microphone
yeah i can't hear myself in my life oh
that's what it is it's a hearing thing
you did mention yeah yeah i do have that
man oh there we go there he's blasted
out
megan is uh turning up the volume on
rob's ear oh my god that's such a
difference now because if i speak like
this that hurts my ears yeah yeah
back here okay
rob has hearing
rob was telling us the other day he's
got hearing damage what do you suppose
that's from is that you said you're
saying that
man i really delete files i completely
forgotten you said that yeah i remember
that because we were talking about how
our eyes are going charlie
yeah my eyes are my eyes are great my
ears are [ __ ]
can't hear anything the good news about
hearing loss is that if you can't hear
it it didn't happen so
you don't know what you don't hear but
with sight
you guys can see that you can't see what
you're supposed to see you know what i'm
saying yeah
oh
[Music]